critics of the president and this
channel are howling that we're putting
the country in danger so what's our
crime accurately reporting the alarming
bias within special counsel Bob Muller's
investigation despite the fact that
Muller and his team have unearthed the
no evidence of so-called collusion
between Trump and Russia the left
considers it basically it's a crime to
even raise legitimate questions about
the staffing and the tactics of the
Muller investigation and they're now
going into full-on apoplexy this has
been a months-long orchestrated frankly
pathetic and also dangerous attack it's
a real example of the divide in the
country and how conservative media is
fueling that divide right now they are
fomenting a constitutional crisis what
they are doing could lead to violence oh
really Joe come on even you don't
believe that so let's get this straight
the Democrat smear machine can run 24/7
maligning President Trump they use
innuendo and anonymous leaks but the
special counsel is beyond reproach they
have their billionaires like Tom Styer
launching these absurd and Pietschmann
efforts on TV they have Hollywood
infecting their programming with tedious
anti-trump vitriol and who knows how
many congressmen and Senators are now
demanding the president's resignation
yet they want us to tone it down and
they want us to what we refrain from
exposing the rank conflict presented by
current members of the Muller team
people like Jean Erie and Andrew
Weissman we can't mention them in their
work warped world view you can call for
a president who by the way oversees the
FBI to step aside because of decades-old
allegations but we can't call for the
resignation of Deputy FBI director
Andrew McCabe who's at the heart of this
entire mess who isn't that nifty
it's like heads you win tails we lose
nice try
we have every right to report on the
abuse of power within any
agency of government a principal
Democrats used to favor indeed if anyone
has attacked law enforcement unfairly
over the years it's the Democrats and
their enablers and the media who can
forget Fanning the flames in st. Louis
or Baltimore this is the same media who
denigrated law enforcement officers for
years in defense of social justice
warriors and false narratives and we
equip police with all these powers and
no training that doesn't just affect one
segment of the community that impacts
everybody let's make that clear the city
is not burning because it needs
protesters the city is burning because
the police kill Freddie gray I do not
trust this oh they're bad so they must
have done something wrong and they
deserve what they had coming rationale
which is the same one we hear from the
CIA as we hear from police in the case
like Michael Brown our hearts are out
there marching with them they've never
challenged the lie of hands up don't
shoot
and remember they lapped up the false
narrative that the police killed Freddie
gray it was all a crock it was all done
to cast aspersions on police and
empathize with certain minority
activists law enforcement did not get
the benefit of the doubt in those cases
and oftentimes that is the case with
them so no I'm not dissuaded for a
nanosecond by their phony claims of
shock and dismay over conservatives who
have the temerity to challenge Bob
Muller Jim Comey and Andrew McCabe and
let's not forget what the president said
last week about the rank and file of
that very agency of the FBI when you
return home to your local precincts I
want you to deliver a message to your
fellow officers the President of the
United States has your back 100% yeah it
definitely sounds like he and his
followers don't support the FBI look the
fact is what the left is really irked
about let's be honest here is that the
president is actually following through
on his major promises and by the way we
saw this today with the announcement of
our new Americans
a strategy henceforth we will use a
principled realism to deal with our
allies and our adversaries we see China
now for what it is it's a state-run
power aggressively seeking global
dominance we'll work with them when they
can but we have our eyes wide open same
with Russia although let's face it they
have an economy smaller than Francis
it's not quite China our approach to the
world now will be consistently grounded
in our America first ideal it's a total
complete repudiation of Obama Obama
citizen of the world claptrap that we
heard about so often for his eight years
so no wonder the left is totally
unhinged soaring economy tax reform
about to pass confidence hi Isis smashed
deportations up foreign policy refocused
and no we are not tired of winning but
as we do so we will continue to ask
uncomfortable questions at times about
Bob Muller's team or any other part of
the government where corruption might
lie it's our job and that's the angle